right so today we are joined here on
stage with some of the amazing Studios
we have here in the nordics but before
we start by the show of hands how many
of you are from the Nordic so I actually
grew up in the nordics
oh just a few of you how many are
working for a studio or a company Studio
that's located in the nordics OR
headquartered out of the nordics
even fewer amazing so who are you
really cool
so but before we kind of start let's
make sure that everyone is on the same
page so this is the world at least
according to the Mercator prediction
from 1594. if I remember
we're here right now
San Francisco
West
and this is very naughty list
as you can see it pretty much on the
same latitude as Alaska and Siberia
it's interesting
and this is the nordics
there are five sovereign states and a
few autonomous regions
we are about 30 million
people and the biggest country is Sweden
and we are about slightly larger than
California as comparison
but before we start
this is the Google Cloud team in the
nordics I'm the guy to the left if
that's unclear
there's 11 hours trying to make the
Swedish Studios and the Nordic Studios
build successful games
most of us are here in this room so if
you want to have a chat go find us
afterwards outside we will be waiting
for you to have a good chat on stuff
but now it's time to meet the real stars
of this session
so absolutely delighted to have you guys
here on stage with me today so we have
rope we have John and Marco
absolutely happy you can join us here
today
so
why don't we do some introductions
and why don't you start rope tell us who
you are and what you do
this one okay hi I'm Robert I'm a server
engineer working on a new game at the
moment at supercell
um been at the company for six years
for me being a server engineer basically
means doing almost everything at the
moment because we're we're working with
really small teams uh and yeah it's kind
of
everything
okay hello hello it's super nice to be
here in CDC and also in this panel so my
name is Marco I'm working in fingers so
it's as a head of product marketing uh I
have a around 10-year experience in the
mobile games I've been developing games
leading games leading development teams
Etc and now I'm focusing on product
marketing so thank you
and I'm John Fuller nice to meet you all
um from Ireland so I have plenty to say
about the early days of the nordics
regions
and I've been in Sweden for
um 2003 20 years
um and it's some of that time with havoc
and most of that time with our land
Studios what do I do I was a developer
and then I've done everything since like
Tech director EP and now I'm a CTO for
Avalon Studios group
amazing so
super thankful for coming for having you
here today so amazing Studios uh you've
done a lot of stuff but why don't you
tell us you know a one minute overview
of of your studio and kind of what games
your most famous for I guess
you can start dropping you have them hey
Mike yep it's uh one minute yeah super
solo I guess yeah known for Clash of
Clans Clash Royale Boom Beach Heyday but
all stars so we're
we're making these games that we aim to
have people playing for years and
hopefully can manage that then uh
uh set a quite a high bar for ourselves
and try to build these Global games and
the company is going to structured into
this kind of company of companies a
bunch of startups working inside the
company this kind of sales where the
name comes from us so it's a interesting
place hey I'm I mean it's my wife plays
Hay Day so okay
he's not a gamer we're used not to be a
gamer taste so that's a good thing
Monaco tell us about fingersoft okay
okay
um fingers of this is is located in all
so if you saw the map about the nordics
there it was a Finland and it is the
topper part of the Finland so we are
located in quite a North there uh we are
famous about our Hill Climb Racing game
so he'll come racing one and Hill Climb
Racing two those games have both accured
uh more than 2 million downloads
worldwide so it was we are currently
focusing on those and and also thinking
about what what new we can build around
those games and I think some of you have
probably seen we have uh started to
solve plans for our our new game called
the low Echo Hill Climb Adventure so
it's available in certain countries as a
company we are just 10 years old and we
have more a bit more than 100 persons
working there and we have I think around
20 different is there so quite a diverse
company and and growth a lot in in over
the last 10 years
I'm gonna try this one okay can you hear
me if I speak
so
um I guess Avalanche Studios was the
original name it's been in business for
uh shortly or soon to be 20 years
um originally very focused on open World
sandbox big explosive action adventure
games like just cause that series
um and Mad Max and Rage 2 those sorts of
games and then more recently A
self-published games
and where we use our proprietary Tech to
do
um yeah sort of unique experiences like
the hunter Call of the Wild which is an
outdoor recreational
game or generation zero second
Extinction like Co-op
um yeah smaller kind of unique
experiences
um 20 years as I said location in Sweden
in Stockholm and Malmo and then a studio
in New York and Liverpool recently
that's us amazing
cool how many have played any of the
games that you're supposed to just
mentioned
there you go well done
they're all supercell
thanks yeah I guess I should mention
that we're located in Helsinki the
capital of Finland we have a we have an
office actually here in San Francisco
also on cool so I mean we're all
representatives in other countries
um we we grew up here maybe not yujon
but so so we kind of know what it's like
to grow up in in the dark north
um
we are pretty successful in other things
like ice hockey um
but and and but maybe not gaming
industry and music industry would quite
successfully as well so so
why do you think the Nordic countries
has been successful when it comes to
game development
yeah sure
um
so I guess historically
um the the region is
has had a good infrastructure
um it's infrastructure as in is high
speed internet and availability to
technology
I think it's a pretty
um pretty like
technically capable like Workforce
um then I also think that sort of the
demo scene
was very prominent in the I guess 90s
like mid 90s around the sort of early
console days
um and yeah a lot of like
demo games
um and people doing I guess
people in the nordics also have quite an
entrepreneurial spirit so they're not
afraid to take a risk and start
something small do something with
friends maybe the dark Winters I mean
the problems really sink their teeth
into it
um but you'll see a lot of I think it's
reflected now but it's also reflected in
the sort of 2000s
a lot of small companies starting
something and the cost of failure is not
that high it's a quite a good
um very good Safety Net in the North
Safety and that good sort of social
um structure so it's a lot of different
variables but uh and I guess you can see
that spreading not just to the the games
industry but also a lot of high-tech
Industries also succeeding
that makes sense what do you think Rob
yeah definitely how can we agree with
that and uh for me it's been also the
demo scene where like
bunch of my friends and like my
generation also is is ruled that that uh
yeah that that has had a big big impact
and um yeah the support network like I
am I'm a beneficiary of that free
education just being able to kind of
like basically walk into a university
with computer science department and
yeah it's uh there's a lot of
compounding factors and of course the
darkness and a lot of computers and
there's not much else to do it than
coding or just playing games and yeah
that
um we are
[Music]
kind of humble but still quite focusing
people that if we start to do something
we usually do it at the end and instead
of maybe instead of having a lot of chat
and we are focusing more on doing things
and I think that's something that helped
us to do those long game projects and
also of course because we have managed
to get some success there early days
after for example the mobile gaming and
then made a successful companies it have
then attracted more investors and an
interest to the Western Audi Council
should have been held at the game
companies or startups to get funding and
through that we have been able to create
a new success stories there that makes
sense that and coffee I think I looked
this up actually the the Nordic
countries are the five Nordic countries
are top six when it comes to to coffee
drinking in the world uh per Copita and
the only non-norly countries that's on
the top six list is actually the
Netherlands but is it the games industry
that's driving coffee drinking or is it
the coffee drinking that's that's a good
question you can buy the raw actually
I'm not sure so so when it when it comes
to this because we started early we
talked about the day we demo scene we we
know that you know a lot of these
companies are quite prominent has been
around for a long time
how are our gaming Studios is different
or are they different in the nordics I
mean is it kind of difference in in kind
of what games we make or or how we work
in the studios
do we have a different culture here even
what do you think
well I can start I
I it is a bit hard for me to say that
how it is happening outside the nordics
but at least in our company and what I
have seen what is happening in the
Finland I think you know I don't know
other countries that that we are working
in really open uh open environment there
inside the company so people are relaxed
and they have a lot of freedoms and we
try to keep the hierarchies low and game
teams in our case are also working
independently so they have a kind of
authors over there overdoings and of
course it gives us challenges for for
the company and the teams that they are
having a lot of freedom but they have a
lot of responsibility there and also we
are looking after uh well-being of our
employees so especially for example in
fingersoft we started them
uh
uh our a bit less than a year ago
experiment that we started to test the
kind of thing that we offer uh for for
the people 90 salary if they are doing
80 of their time so basically you can
work eight only eighty percent but you
get 90 percent of salary and then that
was a kind of successful thing inside
the company of of course everybody is
not a cultivating that or willing to do
that but
and after this trial in uh at the
beginning of this year we decided that
we continue with this one at least the
moral of it and I think it's really
really good is helping the people to
balance their work and on a home time
and so on
yeah cool is it I mean so it voluntarily
if you if you choose to accept you you
can choose it yeah okay cool it's made
in the way that you are working like a
shorter days during the week not in the
way that you have one extra freedom I
got it what do you think
yeah I think that's probably
um I mean I I don't I'm not sort of
hands on with all of the different uh or
companies in the different countries in
the nordics but I see some common themes
and the work-life balance and a sort of
commitment to those places being a
long-term home for developers is a very
a very strong theme
maybe because it's a closed Market it's
not you don't have the whole sort of of
the USA at your disposal or at least we
didn't there's a boom going on at the
moment
um where a lot of international Talent
is interested in in looking at
the nordics as a potential home but uh
to try to you know I think it
working for a game development company
has to be somewhere where you can be 5
10 15 years and still get challenged and
still so there's a lot of common themes
then I think there are a lot of things
that are unique
um like when I look at Finland I see
um Strong mobile background and maybe
that comes from Nokia and sort of
Industry I also see a lot of but with
Ericsson in Sweden so exactly yeah yeah
um well I guess King is is another
another big player in that field I see a
lot of racing games as well which is
probably reflected in finland's Hobby
interest in racing as well so there
might be some sort of Personality
applied to the the games and the genres
that are chosen
um I don't know why we've done action
games I don't know what it says about us
but
yeah I don't know anyway
what do you think Robert yeah I do agree
with the work-life balance and and
that's super soil I I do notice that
people come there and stay stay for a
long time I've been there for six years
now at the company and and I guess one
thing that I've seen
throughout the time I've been in the
games industry in Finland I've seen this
kind of very very open attitude between
the companies on sharing knowledge and
kind of having this welcoming scene of
game developer developers that is kind
of trying to like lift everybody up with
the title if somebody success is
successful and like I think that was
like we had a company before I joined
supercell and yeah that startup was kind
of a probably a part of this Boom at
some point on getting investment into
mobile games and there's a lot of people
who were like helping with that and the
Finnish kind of seeing in like all of
the Investments and like helping others
with tech and like sharing knowledge is
is really strong
yeah
I mean it's interesting the the
different kind of shorteners or type of
games that we do we mentioned a little
bit in Finland there were a lot of
racing games is interesting but on the
other hand you have two drivers in the
Formula One circus so so it kind of goes
to kind of interest in in what we do and
not sure why we Sweden didn't do AAA
games with a lot of action it would
interest no but I mean so so do you see
any Trends in in how we make games
um I mean a lot of things happen in the
world
um
so are are things changing how we've
done things in the past 20 years because
we've been around for some time
you know Louisiana Trends in either
creative part or or the tech part
um
yeah I think
um which is maybe a continuation of that
point where you said that we sort of
collaborate a lot and we're free to
share I think that we see
um the the games industry and the number
of players and where they come from is
so rapidly expanding that we're not
really competing with each other for
like a spot on the second row of the
Shelf in a in a
um shopping mall
um we're we're competing together to try
to
make games for as many people and
demographics as possible so we've seen a
massive increase in the numbers and the
types of people that probably has
increased faster than we can meet that
demand yeah but that's a definite Trend
that has a lot of active discussions in
our studio and
um
a lot of new studios are also trying to
figure out ways to
um tailor experiences and tailor games
to a very changing
audience yep rapidly expanding
um any other Trends yeah I guess a
massive one is the fact that and I guess
mobile games has been particularly good
at at uh
latching onto it but that's that
uh with kids now I can say this with
some confidence
um games are becoming at least as much
to do with the sort of gameplay
experience
they're at least as much to do with the
social platform
and a place to hang out and a place to
share your experiences and a place to
um whereas you know maybe I would have
gone over to a friend's house and sat on
the couch and watched a TV show or
something
um you know people want to play games
together whether that's multiplayer or
slightly more distant like asynchronous
multiplayer mobile experience or
um even games like Roblox and Minecraft
sort of the the platform is at least as
important as the actual
gameplay mechanics and and Loops yeah I
remember when The Last of Us came out
and my kids got it and they were playing
in our country house and me and my wife
was sitting down on the couch actually
watching them play
um for for for a couple of hours because
it was kind of watching a movie a little
bit I think that's kind of basically
what you're saying a little bit as well
yeah and players now watch other players
enjoying the gameplay absolutely and
enjoy dissecting it and talking about it
and
sharing other people's experience
well yeah I have to admit that I've been
in my development like manhole for a
while so I'm looking at Trends is kind
of hard but one thing is maybe technia
like uh one thing that is kind of
obvious looking at the competition and
like having high Ambitions for new games
like uh trying to do
more higher quality assets and like
seeing how high the quality bar is like
getting on mobile also and there's like
a lot of variety in the game so the um
I guess this is like a it's a trend
always that the competition is getting
tougher all the time and like we have to
be better at like how how we manage our
how do we get new content into the game
faster and have our tools being up to
bar and like uh
so that's that's my like immediate
concern that Trend that we we just need
to be keep uh keep taking risks even
though we have like a lot of success
with the live games kind of like be able
to take risk and try to develop new
things also
like on the side and with the new games
and like that's that's been like my
focus like mostly yeah I think
competition is an interesting word
because my feeling is that when when a
sister company to us have a successful
game we're quite proud of that we're not
very jealous obviously we can be jealous
in some ways but we were quite proud
when with our other companies are
successful as well what do you say Marco
yeah I I agree with this competition so
I think the competition nowadays is
quite tough there in in the mobile
especially in the mobile game in the
industry they have in this changes in uh
related user acquisition and
also more and more games are coming
coming in constantly and then it's the
amount is increasing there so basically
the same same kind of uh Trend that you
Robert said that you have to be kind of
um two more and faster and better all at
the same time and I'll still give give
to good quality and your players are
happy and I think one thing what I think
is in some level trending in and it's
this Global training is it's the
consolidation of a gaming industry and
articles and the mobile gaming gaming
history and I think it's visible also in
the nordics that
traditionally in the nordics I think we
have had a lot of discount small game
companies kind of startup kind of game
companies where we have added from one
to ten versions working there and I
think nowadays that there are more
physical merges and accuracies happening
and some of those smaller companies are
disappearing from the field and I think
those successful companies even they are
success in the scope of England or the
nordics or in globally are actually
accurate then by the bigger place global
multibilliant you know company so it's
decreasing the diversity there in in in
the mobile mobile industry and that's
that's one Trend and I believe it's
going to continue is it good or bad I I
don't know maybe would be nice to see
more more new companies so if you are
have ever thought to build or start up a
game company please do do that times are
more tougher than a year ago or five
years ago but we need to those smaller
companies too bringing new ideas and
then keep the crowd running in the game
industry absolutely so I mean you
mentioned the consolidation that goes on
the game Market has been around for like
two or three years or something like
that but so it's obviously that affects
the business so are there other Trends
you know these or these Trends how do
they affect the business I mean do you
have to be more agile do you have to be
faster do you have to be
or just better
where do you think this Trends how how
do they affect the business
yeah I think
um particularly live games like the cost
of creating Digital entertainment uh I
guess mobile may be shifted slightly but
the cost of in our business where we
don't do mobile games
sort of more polygons higher production
values
has just risen astronomically
um and that you know the cost per minute
of entertainment has risen and then we
have our own kind of economy for that
for open World sandbox games but even
there the demands are pretty
um pretty harsh
so
the our type of game is our our win
there is to make sure that we we're not
doing you know once off consume once and
then leave aside
um we want to
engage players with the world or an
experience or an IP and then try to make
sure that they can stay engaged and we
see or I think a lot of people in this
in this Branch see that that's also what
players want they want to sort of keep
and one of the reasons that they leave
is because you can't really keep up with
the with feeding content quality content
for players that have really enjoyed
your game experience yeah so that's a
challenge
um and it speaks to sort of the tools
and the production apparatus that you
talked about
um maybe that's exactly why supercell
has been successful because they've
managed to do that over and over again
yeah essentially yeah
Yeah
well yeah I think it's like like um it
often it's not mentioned that it's it's
probably even harder or at least as hard
as coming off with something new to keep
the live games going like class has been
there for over a decade yeah
and try to keep the focus on the players
on what the players want and serving
that Community it's yeah
but yeah it's a tough one for the live
game teams yeah absolutely
yeah I think with the games everything
starts from the experience and
experiences what they are providing and
I think one one big thing there actually
in the fingers of that I think also all
the others are not as focusing is the
understanding that our customers so you
play here so what you are doing there
what kind of place you are what you are
expecting from our game so instead of
developing features what we are thinking
other kind of best for the game we have
to also understand what the players are
one one thing from our game and then I'd
use those both two things together so as
an additional as we talking earlier that
you do more do faster and do better also
take two signal consideration super easy
super easy so uh
that's the last thing
um like 30 seconds each and let's start
with you Marco what's next for
fingersoft where is where we will see
fingers of end up in one two yeah or or
already mentions via um developing and
now uh we are in soft launch without any
title Lego Hill Climb Adventure so it's
a collaboration game made with the Lego
it's available in in selected countries
it's a
for a racing game in a similar way as a
hill climb racing games but it was also
different it's the kind of story and
Adventure driven driven version of that
the core gameplay is still driving but
uh we are expecting that we can bring
new experiences with that game also we
are continuing the development of our
existing game so Hill Climb Racing the
original one and the health American too
so new updates are coming coming
constantly and we're adding new features
and fine-tuning the existing ones and I
think there are a lot of kind of um for
cool things happening there and as an
addition for for this we are also
developing the next version of uh hill
climb racing games so Hill Climb Racing
3 is underdevelopment we understand that
when will it be out
when it's ready
but yeah it's going to be a new version
of a in this hill climb racing games
series and I in this version we are
moving uh towards the real-time
multiplayer experiences so we want to
play is to play play the same races
together at the same time and also we
are moving from this 2D environment into
3D environment to provide a more Rich
content for photo players so cool these
are things Avalanche what's next for
I've launched for interviewer companies
that's part of everyone yeah yeah
um I guess we will continue working on
our big sort of open world action games
um we have this game Raven bound coming
out this month
I'm looking forward which is new it's
like uh open world with some roguelites
yeah some new elements for us anyway
um I think a lot of our games are
um starting to lean into sort of
community engagement features like
changing the game live when while
listening to the community so we're
building those into
um yeah games across our studio
um and yeah we're continuing to develop
our proprietary Tech
cool lots of exciting projects nice and
finally rope let's make for supercell
can you share uh there's five games live
that are gonna review the received
updates all the time so it's uh I'm not
the actually right person even to
summarize those so so a lot of a lot
going on with the live games and then
there's multiple new game teams uh we're
hoping to get something out but that's
probably all I can say at the moment and
we we also work on our proprietary
engine and uh yeah that there's gonna be
a lot of that development happening and
yeah new games try to hire more people
that's about it cool
gems thank you so much for joining us
here on stage today and thank you all
for joining us here personally I don't
think it's just one thing that made the
Nordic companies successful I think we
got a bit lucky
especially in the early days
uh I think we worked really hard
and kind of now we're counting waiting
this Legacy a bit
and it's probably the coffee
thank you so much for joining us here
today let's have a chat
and give this the answer this Roundup
close as well
[Applause]